good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van
horn from the university of virginia i am
very pleased to welcome you to this edition
of our 2021 2022 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
each friday we enjoy presentations from leading
thinkers about the promise opportunities and
hurdles associated with ai applications in the
biomedical sciences selected participants in
our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating in person
grant project development workshop to be held
here in historic charlottesville virginia uh
in june i am delighted to welcome our speaker
today dr latonya trotter from the university of
washington in seattle professor trotter is an
associate professor at the the in the department
of bioethics and humanities at university of
washington she is a sociologist of medicine
who studies the existence and reproduction
of inequality in the medical workplace in
her work she takes an institutional view
of ethics by considering how social workpla
and workplace institutions shape the notions
of responsibility and our understanding of
what constitutes good or ethical decisions by
individual professional or organizational actors
she explores these and other questions in her
first book entitled more than medicine nurse
practitioners and the problems they solve for
patients healthcare organizations and the state in
continuing our 2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme litany's lecture today
is entitled promise or peril the algorithmic
intelligence and racial discrimination in
healthcare provider bias is a known driver
of racial disparities in health care delivery
and through minimizing provider discretion uh
applications of algorithmic intelligence have
been have the potential to reduce this kind
of bias but they also have the power to further
institutionalize discriminatory logics throughout
the same mechanism in her lecture today latonya
will be describing how this transmutation of
medical authority alters the institutional
and interactional context of the healthcare
encounter in a manner that raises new versions
of old concerns at the intersection of bioethics
and the reproduction of racial inequality as
always we are streaming the suction live and for
recording by youtube and if you are watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for latonya
via the chat feature in their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so for
the lecture and with that welcome latonya
we are so excited to hear from you today
thank you so much for joining us ah well thank you
so much uh for that warm and generous introduction
you know you know speaking for myself i was
really pleased to be invited to give this talk
and to have the chance to speak
directly to early career scholars
who have so much promise to do good
work and to make positive change
i don't however come to you as an expert
on robots or artificial intelligence
but i do have one or two things to say about
algorithms because although algorithmic
thinking has gotten faster more efficient and more
intelligent so to speak the use of algorithms in
the medical workplace is a fairly old technology
still i do think i owe you a bit of an explanation
about when and where i enter this conversation
so that you can better understand what's to come
so i'm a sociologist who thinks about the
reproduction of inequality and injustice
and so i come to the field of bioethics as
less a philosopher than a social scientist
and as a social scientist i focus quite deeply on
everyday workplace interactions i see places like
clinics and hospitals as not just places where
patients go to have their conditions treated
but it's places where people go to work so
i'm less interested in abstract questions
of what one ought to do and more interested
in ascertaining how workers understand what
one might do which is to say i'm interested
in understanding how choice sets get created
in the medical workplace because day and night
workers in health care are making decisions and
some of these decisions are mundane or routine
and some of them are life or death but all of
them shape patient outcomes and experience and
i'm particularly interested in understanding
why it seems to be the case that reproducing
inequality is so often the default choice
for those decisions because make no
mistake that does seem to be the case
because health disparities are a real and robust
finding in the u.s context black people have worse
health outcomes than the white populations so
you might want to know with a little bit more
specificity about which outcomes exactly i'm
talking about and i can safely say pretty much
all of them when i first started studying health
disparities this was one of the most startling
facts that i learned because whether you're
talking about chronic diseases like diabetes
or looking at a range of different forms
of cancer on almost every measure african
americans have a higher prevalence and a poorer
prognosis and when you see the same trend
for so many outcomes it starts to seem unlikely
that they're a product of different mechanisms
so scholars began searching for common mechanisms
right and so in doing so they turned their gaze
away from the bodies of individuals and their
habits and upstream to the level of structure
so scholars began looking at factors that
affect whole communities and populations
such as residential segregation environmental
racism and differential access to quality k-12
education now most of these
structural causes are produced
outside the purview of medicine in the medical
workplace except that is for racism itself
you have scholars like david williams bruce link
and joe phelan who have argued that racism is the
common fundamental cause of both downstream and
upstream factors and the place where racism is
most visible and impactful in health care
is at the level of the medical encounter
so we know for example that provider bias is
a real and observable practice such that a
patient's race is an independent predictor of low
quality care so when a 2005 report published and
produced by the institute of medicine they found
for example that race the race of the patient
predicted a lower likelihood of receiving
appropriate cardiac care receiving kidney
dialysis or transplants or receiving the best
treatments for stroke cancer or aids treatment
and even when you hold constant variables like
insurance status income age and severity of
condition these these relationships remain robust
now the most commonly cited explanation for these
differences in care is implicit bias so implicit
bias is something that all human beings do
right our lightning fast cognition relies
on stereotyped rules of thumb for its speed
but the shape of many of these rules are not
hardwired but are culturally and socially produced
sociologist eduardo benia silva has written about
white americans penchant of segregating themselves
from others in social life and housing education
informal socializing and family formation
i might add that this segregation is achieved not
through peaceful preference but generally through
illegal or violent forms of exclusion so for
bania silva this segregating behavior has created
what he calls a white habitus such that racialized
thinking and its associated biases go unchallenged
through intra-racial socializing or meaningful
relationships so since white healthcare workers
are no less likely to have been socialized in a
white habitus they come to work with many of the
same implicit biases as the general population i
also don't want to leave out explicit bias because
although implicit bias is easier to talk about
and so it often receives the most focus in the
literature and in the popular works but explicit
racial bias by healthcare providers is also
a real and observable practice so quantitatively
a 22 survey whose results were published in jama
found that 21 of patients report having
experienced an overt act of racial discrimination
the qualitative data is even more evocative in
her 2019 book invisible visits scholar tina sax
talks about the ways that black middle-class
women navigate the health care system and this
book is notable because again she's focused on
black middle-class women so class or access to
health care is not the predominant factor and
yet her respondents described in gruesome graphic
detail a lifetime of healthcare encounters that
ranged from the uncomfortable to the traumatic
but i think it's important to point out that
racial ideology and thought and practice
is not as some may think just the residual left
over um from science i.e it's just standing in
for the leftover unscientific beliefs yet this
racial ideology is often implicated within
the education and training of health care workers
so sociologist anne warning did a 2012 study
examining the way that scientists write about
and teach racial difference and she found that
the idea that race is a biologically real and
relevant category is alive and well in science
and so when providers in training are poised
to believe through that training that race
is biologically real then it becomes easier
for theories of racial difference to take hold
and take hold it has and it's rather famous
now 2016 study by hoffman and colleagues
they found that a surprising number of medical
students and residents endorsed what they call
false racial beliefs such as that black people
have thicker skin than white folks that they
age more slowly than whites and that they're
more impervious to pain moreover the study
found that a belief in these false beliefs was
correlated with medical errors and pain assessment
and since pain assessment is a diagnostic
criteria for many conditions and illnesses
the potential impact of these beliefs is probably
much broader than the pain assessment itself
and these findings refer specifically to medical
students and residents but since medical knowledge
is to some extent a shared resource it's likely
that nurses respiratory therapists occupational
therapists also believe in at least some of this
racialized knowledge and this is where the promise
of algorithmic intelligence comes in because to
the extent that racism is a part of the medical
encounter and is reproduced within it it has
the potential ai has the potential to disrupt
its reproduction primarily by reshaping the
behavior of the provider within the interaction
so explicit bias and diagnosis and treatment will
be much more difficult to perform when there is an
algorithm alerting them that they're not following
the evidence in terms of care and when that
algorithm is not just in a published guideline
but is rather embedded in an automated tool but
they will have to affirmatively account for if
they um decide to deviate from that decision
which is another way of saying the burden of
proof will be higher when one decides against the
standard of care produced by the algorithm it also
has the potential to reshape implicit bias so we
know from the psych literature that when you make
people aware of their hidden or implicit biases
they're also better able to through conscious
action think their way towards less bias so the
ai then becomes a part of a set of cognitive new
cognitive resources that the provider uses so not
just through constraint but through making them
more conscious of their incorrect bias decision
the ai then will have the potential to alter um
implicit bias and finally there's the potential
to disrupt the transfer of racialized knowledge
through in informal cultural transmission that
happens both at home through primary socialization
and through medical education so as medical
students and residents learn to rely on algorithms
a part of their cognitive toolkit the influence of
racialized views from their upbringing or as
dispensed from professors or attendings will
wane but in order for this promise to come to pass
we do have to pay careful attention to the perils
because it is i would argue an unfortunate truth
that the same mechanisms that have the potential
to reduce provider bias may simply shift the
decisions to other institutional locations
where the source of the bias will be more hidden
and thus less unaccountable to critique and change
so while ai promises to intervene on provider
bias it does so by decreasing autonomy so when you
decrease the scope and number of decisions that
workers make the sort of power embedded in those
decisions doesn't disappear it simply moves so
one of the things that i hope to illustrate today
is that the places where it moves to are
sometimes difficult to trace to hold to account
and the decisions therefore more
difficult to intervene on and to change
and also although there's nothing particularly
laudable about provider bias right the one
thing it has going for it is that it's not
particularly efficient and what i mean by that
is that individual workers are biased in slightly
different ways which means that the impact then
is variable so if we think to that 2016 study that
looked at racial the possession of racial beliefs
in med students and residents not all students
held those beliefs right and holding those beliefs
did not change the decision-making of everyone
who held them however when aspects of the decision
are moved from this landscape of individual
variability you may get less bias but you
may also get more efficient bias bias with no
variability such that racial beliefs become
in effect racial facts produced and reproduced
with 100 efficiency by the algorithm
and finally in my talk i want us to think about
and think through the conditions of the worker
because one of the things that workers do is
participate in everyday acts of resistance to
employer control right so when we think about
algorithmic logics they're not just shaping
some kind of abstract encounter but shaping the
behavior of employees through surveillance and
constraint so when you have a society that is
structured so unrepentantly around inequality
right the sort of um spaces of resistance are
often the moments where workers make a way out of
no way and in healthcare they do this not just for
those for themselves but for their patients so i
want to consider the healthcare worker as not just
a source of technical work or a dispenser of acts
or activities that can be made more efficient
and less biased but as a worker who improvises
and through doing so creates the ground for
thinking about and organizing a new reality
so in the remainder of my talk i want to flesh
out some of these particular perils through
looking at a series of illustrative cases so you
know even though we're all poised to think about
ai as being something that exists in
the future i often find it helpful
to begin in the past because often the things
that we think are new are actually quite old
so i want to start with a case that probably many
of you are familiar with and that's the case of
the spirometer and i want to start with this case
you know not because it's really an example of
algorithmic thinking but it's our decision
making but because it's an example of the
efficient reproduction of the kind of racial facts
that often come to underlie such applications
so i'm taking this sort of historical
analysis and understanding of the spirometer
from the work of historian union lonnie lundy
braun her book breathing race into the machine
so this barometer the spirometer is a fairly
simple mechanical instrument used in pulmonary
medicine it measures lung function it generates a
value that providers use to diagnose respiratory
diseases but this tool the one that we use today
is an updated version of one that was developed
during the 1850s during the era of slavery
it was originally developed this barometer
in written to measure the lung function of
industrial workers white industrial workers
but when it moved and technology moved across
the ocean and arrived in the u.s it was taken up
by dr samuel cartwright he was a physician that
practiced in the antebellum south and he had a key
hand in taking this technology and developing for
use here so some of that development was technical
but really mostly it was rhetorical because dr
cartwright was a proponent of racial science
he believed that the racists were different and
that black people in particular were biologically
inferior to whites so for example he is very well
known for arguing before during and after the
civil war that one measure of black inferiority
is that we supposedly had weaker lung functioning
and he used this as an explanation of why
enforced labor either through forcing the
work of the enslaved or through the forced
agricultural labor that came after emancipation
he used this to argue that this sort of forced
hard manual labor was not detrimental to the
health of black americans but was actually good
and beneficial for us therefore legitimating our
place in the labor market in these places so one
of the things that i think is really important to
remember in talking about this piece of technology
is that the spirometer was not a clinical tool
cartwright did not use it to diagnose or
treat patients black nor white he used it
to literally produce race a believer in racial
science he went looking for racial differences
and when you go looking for something you often
find it so one might even say that in addition
to measuring lung function that one of the core
functions of the spirometer is that it was used
to produce racial difference which for cartwright
was synonymous with producing a racial hierarchy
so in her expectation of the case um wendy brown's
work notes that there was disagreement around this
sort of use of the spirometer and disagreement
around the sort of basic fact or argument about
black americans having lower lung function right
and i think this is really important when you're
talking about a historical case that people often
project back in history that everybody thought the
same way in a kind of backwards ideology but even
at the time there was contention and disagreement
you had other white physicians who had had the
occasion um to evaluate the fitness of black
soldiers during the civil war and instead of using
heart rights barometer they use chest measurements
to evaluate fitness and they found no difference
you also had black scholars such as
the statistician kelly miller and the
sociologist w b du bois both of whom denounced
both the ideology of the science as well as the
statistical methods through which cartwright
apparently proved this racial difference
but despite this sort of conflict and disagreement
disagreement it was ultimately cartwright's
perspective view and racial ideas that won
the day and not just his day but ours as well
because of course between the 1850s and now the
physical apparatus of the of the spirometer has
certainly changed and new more accurate data has
been collected since that time but the racial fact
that black people have lower lung capacity
than whites lived on unchanged well after
cartwright was dead and buried such that today
150 years after cartwright's original flawed work
every time a person performs this test or
interprets the results they become implicated
in reproducing this racial fact and more generally
generally they become complicit and reproducing
the idea that black people's bodies are
categorically different than other kinds of bodies
so it's no wonder that medical students hold
fast to their racial beliefs because while some
of their racial beliefs are labeled to be false
others appear to be standard medical practice
so i wanted to go over this fairly well-known
case in part because it's more than an example
of race norming but because i think that
it illustrates three things first i think
it shows us how easily and seamlessly the
past can live through the present and part
by obscuring the existence of the past so in this
particular case you know i highly doubt that there
are very many nurses pulmonologists or respiratory
therapists who perform this test who have any idea
about cartwright who share his ideas about slavery
or share his racist ideas and yet every time they
participate in this act race norming they become
the unwitting mechanism for cementing his legacy
which means that the encounter which is supposed
to be a medical encounter remains vulnerable to
other interests because cartwright was not just
a physician with some mistaken ideas he was an
active proponent of scientific racism and spread
his ideology through a rigorous public defense
of slavery he was someone who made it his
life's work to perpetuate racist biology and
he used his barometer to reproduce that racist
ideology through reproducing race so when we
look at the contemporary exam room although
it may seem that the only people in that room
are the provider and the patient we have
to consider the ways in which cartwright 2
is in that room he's there to the tool
he helped to create and popularize
in his presence he has also become a decision
maker a remote an unavailable dead decision maker
but a decision maker nonetheless so the physical
provider in that room may be racially biased
or not but the decision has been taken out of
their hands it's the machine not the provider
who decides whether to reproduce this racial fact
you also have the reality that the power to resist
has largely been taken from the patient because
while a patient can disagree argue or challenge
sort of visible racism of a provider they cannot
do the same with cartwright's racial ideology he's
a decision maker who's invisible and unaccountable
but who acts with near 100 efficiency
such that the meaning nature and even the actors
in the encounter have been changed in ways
that matter for medical care medical
knowledge and medical decisions
i also wanted to look more closely at a second
case that's less historical and more recent
and that's the case that looks at the measure of
kidney function which is the estimate of globular
filtration rate or the estimated filtration
rate so gfr is a measure of how fast a
person's kidneys filter blood so lower kidney
filtration rates suggest worse kidney health
and worse kidney function so since 1999 race
was a variable that was used in this calculation
and what happened in 1999 was that there was a
single study published which found that black
people in the study had higher kidney filtration
rates on average than than whites at the same
blood creatinine concentrations and it's the
sort of measure of creatinine concentration
um that is sort of the one that's
race norm if you will in the egfr
you also had a second study in 2009 that
found similar findings however critics
of this sort of race norming of gfr have
noted that race is not an explanation
it's merely a proxy for something that's not very
well understood as scholar benjamin asserts race
is itself an algorithm which is thought to
stand in for all kinds of unobserved factors
for example some have some have hypothesized that
the sort of racial difference um in creatinine
clearance can be attributed to muscle mass
but others have asked well if that's the case
why not just measure muscle mass um but neither a
nine in the in the 1999 study or in the 2009 study
neither of these measure um this explanation
or any other explanatory framework so race
is an algorithm being used but it's a really
poor algorithm one that seemed to distract us
from looking for other kind of explanations and
the intensity of that distraction has been quite
fierce and the two decades since the first study
there have been scientific articles opinion pieces
task forces convened and on the ground organizing
to change the use of race in this calculation
but a whole host of scientists and physicians
were publicly resistant to making this change
and the failure failure to
make this change matters
because unlike in the case of the spirometer the
measure of gfr um in the brainstorming of it could
literally mean life or death for black people
because this is this measure is the primary one
through which eligibility for dialysis and
kidney transplant are determined which if
you know the epidemiology of kidney disease the
implications of this are horrifying 35 percent of
all chronic kidney sufferers in the us are black
even though we're only about 13 of the population
so race norm gfr systematically underestimates
the prevalence and severity of kidney disease
which is to say that even though we suffer
more we're less likely to meet the criteria
for a kidney transplant or dialysis or other
interventions because the racial fact produced
was that black people had to have a higher number
to register as having the same amount of illness
so when it came to determining resources
black people had to meet a higher bar a study
by malika mindu and colleagues estimated
that if the race correction were removed
an estimated one out of every three black patients
would be reclassified as having a more severe
stage of chronic chronic kidney disease and up
to one quarter of black patients would have been
reclassified from stage three to stage four of the
disease which is the final state of kidney failure
to trigger more advanced care and
this is just one of many studies
far more than the two that set the standard
yet there remained resistance to changing it
and in fact you know individual hospitals
began changing their organizational standards
first mostly because of political organizing and
pressure by med students and residents a uniform
change in the standard did not happen until last
year and so i wanted to point out this example
for a few reasons first it's because unlike the
spirometer it doesn't just produce a racial fact
it normalizes on equal treatment and it very
efficiently distracted folks from the very real
very observable social fact that black people
were dying at higher rates from kidney disease
and were waiting longer for transplants in
part because of this measure so it's almost
as if this racewarming literally blinded people
to inequality and therefore left them free to
reproduce it and to protect its reproduction
for 20 years and this isn't the only example
in a 2020 article in the published in the new
england journal of medicine this article analyzed
um you know 13 different clinical algorithms that
use a patient's race in the calculations and it
found that in every case the result was to lower
the quality of care that patients of color receive
and finally i think that this case
demonstrates the dangers of algorithms
and used in this sort of institutionalized context
because once they've been institutionalized and
how people understand the disease i.e once this
sort of racial belief becomes a racial fact
um um right it becomes very very difficult to
change right so there were assuredly fights about
the science but make no mistake it's expensive to
change organizational practice and with medicaid
being the primary payer of dialysis and kidney
transplants i put money on the fact that ponying
up more funds to increase care for black patients
was part of the institutional concern and change
so although one study produced a change and a
second legitimated it it took scores to finally
shift on the landscape and to finally make um a
comprehensive change and you know i honestly would
argue that even that change wouldn't have happened
without a political movement headed by students
i also think it's a really good example of
why any conversation on rationing healthcare
should be really wary of the promise of
these so of so-called ethical algorithms
some bioethicists have focused on the promise
of ethical algorithms feration and care
in much the same way that
i talked about the promise
of algorithms to sort of reduce provider bias in
reproducing racism within the healthcare encounter
you know which is that clinicians obviously carry
biases that they bring to these kinds of decisions
and if we had some kind of algorithm that might
make care and the rationing of care i'm more just
i.e you know the algorithm can eliminate biases
and provide consistency for rationing decisions
but you know the egfr example should really give
us pause and wanting to rely on the ethics of
algorithms because the so-called neutral data
going into these calculations were a product
of a commitment to seeing and finding racial
difference and therefore so is the result right
and consequently it naturalizes the conditions
that might lead to a group being deemed a sicker
and less likely to respond to treatment so if that
is one of the measures being used in determining
whether um to provide care to an individual
or not right um these sort of pre-existing
health disparities then become the reason
why um future and further health disparities
um then are reproduced right so just like heart
rights production of race um might obscure um
the environmental sources that produce poor
lung function um in in black adults during the
antebellum south such as higher rates of asthma
such as exposure to um to industrial byproducts
such as poor housing right um his production of
these sort of racial statistics sort of obscured
all of those differences and so similarly an
ethical algorithm that uses for example data
that comes out of pre-existing health disparities
can hide how health disparities actually happen
and the way in which um so there's a way in
which we can think of these algorithms as
potentially holding patients accountable
for the harms perpetuated against them
um instead of focusing our attention on the real
target um so you know lastly i really wanted
to sort of zero in on the specter of worker
resistance um because you know i'm preparing
for this talk i looked at all of the kind of um
corporate and institutional ads sort of touting
the use of ai and health care and when you do that
everyone really focuses in on the level of the
primary form of that relationship let's be
real if through surveillance and constraint
um and the idea right is that the surveillance and
constraint will have the effect of disrupting um
bias right um but it also can
have the effect of disrupting
forms of resistance that employees engage in so
before i talk about the implications of ai um
in the ability of workers to resist um i want
to actually sort of talk about two examples on
existence of resistance so one of these examples
comes from my own experience my own field work
when i was working on my first book
i spent a lot of time with frail
older african-american adults this population of
older adults needed a great deal of support to
remain living independently in the community and
so one of the supports that was really crucial for
maintaining their independence was the assistance
of the support of a home healthcare aide
and i'll never forget the first time i
sat with a man who i'll call mr franks
the first time i met one of his aides i admit
i didn't pay much attention to what it was that
she was doing but i did notice at the end that mr
frank had to sign off on everything she had done
so she had been at his house for about 90
minutes but the form that her agency used for
reimbursement from the payer clearly stated that
she was supposed to in this 90 minutes have bathed
mr frank's perhaps helped him shave did light meal
prep cleaned up after the meal prep and engaged in
light housekeeping um i don't know um if any of
you have ever tried to make a meal clean up after
a meal clean a house bathe and dress an adult in
90 minutes um it really was an impossible task
so i watched the aide sort of take the form
and use her pen and check off all the boxes
even though she had done less than half of all
the things listed and she turned the form over
to mr frank's to sign so my first thought was
is she taking advantage um because i watched her
and um you know i knew that she hadn't done
the things that the forms that she had done
um but i began to sort of keep paying
attention and as this aide and others returned
day after day and i came to a different
understanding of what they were doing
the forum was an attempt at surveillance and
control and it was attempting to hold the aid to
account for doing what was really an impossible
job you know moreover the sort of constraints
of even the 90 minutes were very very difficult
for many of the aides to manage aids who relied
on public transportation um would often arrive
late for their appointments because the agency
really only gave them 30 minutes to go from half
to house and if you've ever tried to take public
transportation from place to place 30 minutes
is never enough so what had emerged was a kind
of give and take all right um so mr franks for
example um didn't just want someone to microwave a
store-bought um um frozen meal which is really the
only way that light meal prep could be a part of
the goals attained in 90 minutes he wanted someone
who would cook so sometimes an aide might spend
45 minutes to an hour cooking up an elaborate meal
that mr frank could eat for several days sometimes
an aide trying to manage for transportation
woes would actually cook the food in her off
hours bring it with her right in order to sort
of try to manage the sort of friction of travel
she would sort of trade this time in and out so
in trading with mr franks he traded in something
that he valued for something that he valued less
for him housekeeping was not really his concern
outside of the kitchen this was something that
was very rarely done by his aides but here the
aid and mr franks were making a way out of no way
through negotiating the form both of them were
agreeing to mislead the agency and the payer that
had dictated that all of these tasks could be done
in 90 minutes this act of resistance of course
could only be and exists because the form was a
fairly poor and inefficient means of surveillance
but this act of resistance was also an act of care
right the aid could have just done the aspects
that she wanted to do but she prioritized
helping mr franks get some of his needs met
within the impossible constraints of her work
so you know when we move up
from the home health care aid
all the way up the chain of command you know we
sort of arrive at a set of workers who we expect
to make autonomous decisions right so in here
i'm sort of referencing the work of idea harvey
wingfield and her book flatlining where she
interviews and spends time with black healthcare
workers in order to understand their experience
working as racialized people in healthcare
and what she found is this that healthcare
institutions participate in racial outsourcing
relying heavily on black doctors nurses and techs
to do what she calls equity work extra labor
that makes organizations and their services more
accessible to a diverse population of people
she also argues that these organizations because
they become more profit driven have really come
to depend on the work of black health care
professionals to perform this equity work
um to increasingly diverse patient populations
but this work is usually and almost always done
without recognition compensation or support but
when they take on this equity work the workers do
get some satisfaction and doing what i call sort
of improvising resistance to the systems that
reproduce inequality when they find themselves
having the power to do so they protected black
patients from institutional racism and they
also work to keep the kinds of institutions
that served low-income populations that cared for
their community so even in the face of constraint
they marshaled resistance and they marshaled
resistance in ways that were specific to who they
were as individuals not just as physicians who
would make the same decision no matter the patient
so i began this talk by asking um that when
it comes to ending racial discrimination and
healthcare is you know algorithmic thinking does
it represent a promise or peril and now i can
confess that this framing was a little bit of a
misdirect because from where i stand ai on its
own is nothing but peril not because i'm afraid
of the future but because i understand our past
no algorithm intelligent automated or otherwise
is going to rid us of racial inequality
so in the last few years we've seen um the
appellation of new to a host of new analyses
so you had michelle alexander's book that came out
the new jim crow in reference to the ways in which
the prison industrial complex reproduces jim crow
system right through the sort of prison system
more recently there's rua benjamin's work the
new gym code that looks at how algorithms in
tech are reproducing racial inequality within
its code and these are both important reads
in part because they reveal that what was old
is new because what was old has remained right
so the racial logics that drove samuel
cartwright in 1850 to defend slavery
is not only embedded in this barometer it's
embedded at the core of our social institutions
but i think there is hope for the future but it
won't be in the specifics of the code or in the
data or in the way which is applied it will be
in changing the social relations themselves so
i started out this talk by positioning myself
as someone who seeks healthcare as a workplace
that's because in many ways it is but
the kind of workplace that it has come
to be doesn't have to be the kind of
workplace um that it is in the future
so much about what the application of algorithms
or the broader suite of tech solutions and
healthcare are about surveillance and constraint
um which to me these words sound exactly like
the industrial workplace right kind of like an
amazon warehouse where the work is boiled down
to a set of tasks and the workers are surveilled
to be more efficient and carrying them out
but that isn't the only way of thinking about
the work because the work could be described
as producing care so when i described the case
of mr franks and his home health care aides
i chose that example for a reason because you know
in the sort of stratified world of home health
care a home health care aid is the lowest status
low in paying position where no one assumes that
workers have or deserve to have any autonomy or
independence but what if we understood these aids
as not simply dispensers of work or doers of task
but as someone with expertise in care and someone
who has expertise in creating caring relations
which is what i found that mr frank's aides
and himself did under stressful conditions if
we saw that the encounter in the same way that
mr franks and his aides did what different data
might we collect not because the data is better
or more accurate but because it reflects a
fundamentally different rendering and value of the
work the worker and therefore the patient who's
being cared for i also chose harvey ringfield's
book on black health care workers to point out
um that these black physicians nurses and and
techs actually know quite a bit about how to go
about making the system better for their patients
and so i want to leave you with the thought
what if instead of extracting value and free
material and emotional labor from these workers
we saw them as sources of knowledge and expertise
and finally one of the things that algorithms
do is that it systematically hides many of the
actors who shape these relations so when thinking
about the illustrative cases that i talked about
i want to point out that part of the reason
why they could be analyzed and critiqued is
because the data and the algorithmic logics
that produced them were freely and publicly
available to historians to med students and to
patient advocates but the future of ai however
promises to be proprietary because our
health care system is proprietary right
so it won't be cartwright in the
exam room it'll be a tech firm
and when questions are raised about the ideology
that produces these algorithms there will be no
response except one carefully crafted from the
marketing or pr department so the real peril of
ai then is that we will continue to reproduce the
same social relations built on inequality and an
imbalance of power favoring corporate elites
because the peril is not an ai it's with us
so with that i will close um and i guess open
the floor for questions latonya thank you so
much that was fantastic i really appreciated
all those little elements that you you kind of
brought to our attention that perhaps you know
we haven't really thought about in terms of you
know the interactions between healthcare and
race and the standards of care is suggested by
algorithms and one of the things which kind of
intrigued me was the notion that you brought up
about the the bias shifting where these biases
kind of like they get embedded into the system
and they just get kind of propagated along and
no one ever asks like why they're there and they
just become facts and then we just come to expect
them and i was i was also intrigued because you
were pointing out these different uh examples
of where some of these things have embedded
themselves i was curious if you were familiar
with the um the science of cranion craniometry
which is the um it was a a technology if you will
from the mid to late 1800s which was considered
very sophisticated in its day it was the device
used to measure the lumps and bumps on your head
to make inferences about the functional areas of
the underlying brain structure and this was used
all over and in fact those little phrenology heads
that you can buy and you know on amazon for about
20 bucks those are really the product of that
which is you know now kind of a debunked science
but it was used in those those days to actually
justify the and met measure and then justify the
inferior intellectual inferiority of of black
americans um justified beliefs about their um
their criminal tendencies their employability
and importantly education and it just took
the residue of this now debunked and you know
misapplied science which seemed very sophisticated
took decades for it to wash out of the system
we're still kind of dealing with its effects today
i was interested if you knew about that or if you
had any other examples of where that kind of thing
has happened um you know there are ways in which
sort of the racial science of the of the 18 and
1900s was really quite prolific and really quite
productive um and so i am sort of familiar um
i hadn't sort of referred to a sort of craniology
i heard it sort of mostly called um the sort of
phenology the sort of production um these sort
of racial differences through looking at one's
head and i i think you know for me you know um the
thing that that becomes really interesting about
these things because there's ways in which when
you sort of go back in hindsight and look at these
there's ways in which the um the sort of process
um through which people believe that they were
producing good science seems vaguely ridiculous
but i think the thing that's quite amazing is the
ways in which murkiness becomes precise when you
are using um data and algorithms right so you're
taking something that seems really quite murky
really quite problematic really really difficult
to reproduce but the moment you put a number
on it it is suddenly transformed into something
that's precise and something that travels right
when you sort of create sort of um data on which
either theories or algorithmic decision making
are overlaid the data itself seems to produce um
legitimacy through the production of precision
so there is something where you know numbers
are almost a rhetorical device um right so you
could talk for example you know about you know
particular theories um that underlie it people
may debate the theory but the moment you produce
numbers there seems nothing left to debate um and
i think that that is you know again you know one
of the things that um you know troubles me about
the idea of data being proprietary and the sort of
algorithmic logics being proprietary um is that it
becomes very very difficult then to sort of unpack
um you know the sort of rhetoric of precision
um that seems to sort of be overlaid here
yeah i i i totally appreciate that and one of
the things which is i think maybe helpful maybe
you can advise us on is how do people who are
developing algorithms they're they're basically
they're going to be the future of ai and that's
you know the people who are participating in our
activities really what can they do to see it
coming and to kind of you know understand it
and recognize it and then to try and you know
tack the other direction to counterbalance
those effects yeah i mean i i thought about this
sort of idea of having something hopeful to say
we appreciate that but i think sometimes
the difficulty is believing or asserting
um that these sort of structural underpinnings
can be improved through an application or through
a tech a piece of technology but there's
there's something that um um you know we
look we look at this you know the you know the
example that i talked about spirometer right
um we look at the ways in which you know
150 years later um you know um you know um
even though the the technology of the spirometer
right um has certainly moved and shifted over time
um the rays in which ways in which we did not
actually see any movement in the in the actual
sort of you know racial fact if you will um that
got reproduced and um and so i think that for me
one of them is really right thinking about um
you know the importance of the publicness of
these algorithms um or the or the logic underneath
them i mean i do not think there's any way that a
proprietary algorithm um that is not open um
to um you know folks thinking it through um
um you know you know with community with scholars
with advocates advocates um you know really have
a sort of hope of um of really sort of not
producing these racial logics in part because
they're embedded in us right um the things that
our society produce produces reflects who it is
that we are and if we haven't grappled with
our own sort of racialized thinking and our
own racial logics everything we produce is going
to reproduce um the society and so really you know
honestly i think it takes um you know a community
of people thinking um through these kinds of
logics i think you know in the sort of um you
know in the sort of broader community for example
of folks who are sort of you know thinking
about sort of um racial data um in their use
and sort of tech um and algorithms outside of
the healthcare there really has been a lot of
sort of ground swell of community organizing
around um you know being at the table and part
of being at the table isn't just to provide ideas
it really is about the transparency of you know
what is happening so that it can be critiqued
and shaped so it really isn't about you know
the thing itself or figuring out how to improve
the thing itself it really is about having these
sort of cultures of transparency and i think the
other way too is you know for me one of the things
reasons why i wanted to focus on um the things
that workers know um is that we often don't know
the things that workers know because we never
bother to ask them because we don't really care
if there's carrying out these stuff right but what
if we did care right what if you know we spent
time right asking them to help us understand how
some of the applications that are being developed
may help them to better do their job of their as
they define it which is usually not the efficient
doing of the work it's about providing quality
care and that really is a value right and it's
a value that is increasingly sort of squeezed out
of health care care is increasingly absent and so
if you have an absence right and a pulling out of
every shred of care under the guise of efficiency
um and sort of getting rid of individual level
variation and therefore bias right um you know
you're you're not going to be able to
create algorithms that actually are going to
reproduce the values of care so you talked a
little bit about the past informing the future
what sort of steps would you like to see
if they could begin today clinicians in the
healthcare industry uh industrial complex
uh what could they do today to help start
mitigating any harm and disparity that these
algorithms are kind of uh you know producing
yeah i mean i think that if you're talking
about the sort of level of mitigation um you
know there are probably sort of more practical
things on that can that can happen you know i've
talked about transparency um i also think that it
matters um who's at the table um so you know again
you know one of the reasons why you know i sort
of focused on what it is that workers know um
is that i don't actually think we have enough
sort of bread and butter providers um at the table
um in the sort of development of these
applications um you know i think we
have providers who are involved but they
tend to be involved with entrepreneurs
um right they don't tend to actually be involved
um simply um as a sort of key stakeholder
into providing sort of community care um and
so i really think that if you took seriously um
the experience that workers have um sort of
navigating this terrain and ask them you know how
what would um a tool look like when what would
a sort of algorithm look like that would make
your work as you define it and as you value
it to be right what would that look like
um because i think right now we are
solving problems as defined by employers
we're not solving problems as defined
by workers and patients so if you ask
patients and and providers to talk
about what problems they want to have
solved you would come up with a very different
kind of end tool than if you asked employers
oh i'm sure you're right and another thing which
kind of as you were thinking speaking i was
thinking about the role of of trust and the the
embedding trust into the algorithms which kind of
made me think about what can we do to encourage
people of color and from you know communities
who are not otherwise well represented in ai
and machine learning and algorithm development
how we encourage them to be more participatory
what can we do to encourage people of color to
you know become coders or to take part in
in these discussions what can we do better
you know as you asked this question i
had a thought that i've never had before
and one of them because i think you'd often
write this sort of quest to sort of you know
the sort of standard idea is you know encourage
people to come to community based meetings and
to sort of ask for their input um um and i
think the other thing is to sort of you know
encourage people to sort of enter in to the
terrain um through um you know being employed
um by a particular company develop developing
ai or a particular lab developing ai
you know um and those often are problematic right
because on one hand it is true that having more
diverse people around the table um you know
has the potential to sort of create more um
diverse ideas you know one of the the
difficulties and problems with always
asking for example lay community members
to sort of show up um is that you know
the experts at the table they're getting paid
for their time the community participants are not
right there are ways in which right always being
asked to sort of be involved in your spare time
on one hand is nice but on the other hand is the
burden yeah sure and i think the second you know
issue with sort of you know you know maybe having
sort of more diverse first faces sort of employing
these organizations is if i'm an employee of
an organization i may look like the community
right and i might try my best right to sort of
speak on behalf of the community but i am also
a worker for this organization right um and so one
of the things that i think would be an interesting
um um you know thing that you know maybe it exists
um i know that we have um some some perhaps some
organizers our people who've been involved in
sort of community-based work in the audience
um is you know allowing the community to
pick an expert to work on their behalf
one who was accountable to them and not to an
employer um but who has the expertise and the time
to sort of show up and do the work i think that
to me that would actually be um a way of having
community input from these various diverse
communities um in a way that's respectful of
their time and for the person has independence
and autonomy as well as the expertise to sort
of speak on their behalf latonya thank you
so much we're at the top of the hour and
this has just been a delightful presentation
it's been wonderful to talk to you and to
to hear your thoughts and to hear your vision
i i just thoroughly enjoyed listening to you
today and uh i'm sure that i'm speaking for all
of our participants and everybody who will watch
this moving forward thank you so much um we really
appreciate it and to everybody who is listening uh
thank you so much and uh we will wish you a great
weekend and we'll see you next week thank you